[Applaus]
Schle du
BR bist du BL mir
deren guten Tag sie sind meine heutigen
Teilnehmer nehm ich
an W du die us Dings bist ich bin nicht
die USI ich bin Charlotte von wilmsdorf
von
wilmsdorf wir haben voning ja und
Dering und möchten Sie sich nicht
vorstellen ich bin der Erwin das ist
Pixi ja also dann essen fen oder wie
bitte her mir
Superpreis ein Dinner inklusive benim
Coaching damit sie mal lernt wie man sie
auührt F immer auf ja super geh ganzen
benim Schi Spen hausessen hier Kampf du
kann ganzeessen erst das Coaching dann
das
Essen gut was wissen Sie über Etikette
dass die saä Katzen W nicht rechtzeitig
aus wissen Sie eine Dame trägt
eigentlich nicht
bauchfrei vollkommen Recht sag mal
spinnst du sie hat doch gesagt vergessen
wir das anders lassen Sie uns eine
typische restaurantsituation simulieren
alles klar auf geht zum
spartelnendlich was Mast was die für
Schnitzel wollen sie der Dame nicht aus
der Jacke helfen W Dame vorbei kommt
schon die
USI du Dame er scheiß der Hund aus
feierzeug bevor sie Dame ist
kom geil hoffentlich haben sie
jägerschnitz oder mit Ananas drauf oder
vielleicht POM
oder mit dem stuhen irgendwo gesehen
prinzipiell sehr gut aber Sie müssen die
Dame natürlich vorwarnen das wie
bitte
[Musik]
und den Kaugummi machen wir bitte
raus spinst du du rimpfig das ist mein
Urkunde SPR nicht so auf gibt jetzt dann
bald was zum Essen der wird schon
grantig ja ja
gleich
sch
colaink oder
wasal
wie bis zur
Oberkante genau super
super er die Dame Hunger
Erwin Erwin die hab
Viecher bist du BL das ist ein Hummer
das ist ganz was
feines nicht
durch ja ich schon nur ein Schwein
trinkt
allein zum zum zum
der der geh sch der sprudelt direkt ja
wenn was was und wenn wir doch zum odel
wird gingen genau
das den zeig den kannst selber fressen
du die ersten fünck K die gingen auf
mich bist richtiger
gentlem soll der echter schaumzen hab
ich da ich bin sofort der richtiger
Gentlemen ST der
ZAT
miten oder bist du oder was dreckspackk
chissens